>> THAT'S WHAT ELON WANTS TO
BRING BACK TO TWITTER IS
REASONABLE EXCHANGE OF IDEAS.
I THINK WE HAVE A REAL PROBLEM
WITH -- PARTICULARLY DISCOURSE
ON TWITTER.
RIGHT?
IF YOU POST SOMETHING AND
SOMEONE POSTS SOMETHING THAT
OPPOSING WHAT YOU SAY, UGH.
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE THAT.
THEY WANT TO SILENCE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE OPPOSING VIEWPOINTS AND
THEN YOU GET ALL THIS POSITIVE
FEEDBACK FROM ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT AGREE WITH YOU YES, I WANT
TO AMPLIFY THAT A BAD WAY TO
EXCHANGE IDEAS AND TO DIALOGUE
ABOUT STUFF.
>> Steve: THERE YOU HAVE GOT JOE
ROGAN PRAISING ELON MUSK FOR
WANTING TO BRING BACK WHAT HE
SAID REASONABLE EXCHANGE OF
IDEAS TWITTER AS THE ORDERS
MASSIVE COMPANY WIDE LAYOFFS
ALTHOUGH THAT SOUNDS LIKE THAT
MIGHT NOT BE TRUE HE TWEETED.
JOINING US IS PIERS MORGAN HOST
OF PIERS NOR BEGAN UNCENSORED ON
FOX NATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO YOU THERE IN
LONDON.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, STEVE.
>> I KNOW YOU LOVE TWITTER.
I JUST LOOKED YOU GOT 8 MILLION
FOLLOWERS YOU LOVE THE ARSENAL
IS DOING SO WELL IN THE SOCCER
WORLD DO YOU DO AGREE IT WOULD
BE A GREAT THING FOR AS WE HEARD
JOE ROGAN SAY REASONABLE
EXCHANGE OF IDEAS TO RETURN.
IN THE PAST REASONABLE EXCHANGE
OF PROGRESSIVE IDEAS AND
CONSERVATIVES HAVE FELT LIKE
THEY WERE PUNISHED NO DOUBT AT
ALL JOE ROGAN IS ARE SPOT ON.
WHAT YOU HAVE SEEN WITH TWITTER
WOKE WORKFORCE BASICALLY SHADOW
BANNING CONSERVATIVE
COMMENTATORS FROM TWITTER FOR A
LONG TIME.
WE ALL KNOW.
THIS THEY HAVE ALSO BEEN ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY BANNING PEOPLE ON
THE RIGHT WITHOUT BANNING PEOPLE
ON THE LEFT FOR SIMILAR
OFFENSES.
IT IS TO ME COMPLETELY
RIDICULOUS THAT DONALD TRUMP, A
RECENTLY SERVING PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES IS CURRENTLY
BANNED FROM TWITTER BUT THE
HEADS OF THE TALIBAN AND IRAN
ARE NOW TO BE ON THAT PLATFORM.
THAT, TO ME, EXPOSES THE
HYPOCRISY OF THE HEART OF WHAT
HAS BEEN GOING ON.
I THINK ELON MUSK, LOOK, I LOVE
ELON MUSK I THINK IS HE SLIGHTLY
CRAZY GUY, BRILLIANT.
IS HE A GENIUS.
HE IS NOT PERFECT.
BUT HE LIVES ON TWITTER HIM
ISSELF IN REALTIME GIVING US HIS
THOUGHTS.
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT IT HE DID ONE
THE OTHER DAY SAYING COMEDY IS
GOING TO BE ALLOWED AGAIN.
LEGAL AGAIN ON TWITTER.
I LAUGHED OUT LOUD HE LIKED MY
RESPONSE.
THREE LAUGHING EMOJIS LIKED BY
ELON MUSK.
THERE AGAIN, IS HE GOING TO
BRING BACK COMEDY, THE ABILITY
TO HAVE A LAUGH, TO BANTER WITH
PEOPLE WITHOUT FEARING GOING TO
GET CANCELED.
LONG OVERDUE AND THE REACTION
FROM THE LEFT, I HAVE TO SAY HAS
BEEN MISERABLY PREDICTABLE.
IT REMINDS ME OF WHEN DONALD
TRUMP WAS MADE PRESIDENT THAT
THEY ALL SAID WE'RE ALL LEAVING
THE COUNTRY.
NONE OF THEM LEFT THE COUNTRY.
AND THE SAME ARE ALL NOW SAYING
CHUCKING THEIR RATTLES OUT OF
THE STROLLER AND SAYING THEY ARE
ALL GOING TO LEAVE TWITTER.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO LOVE
TWITTER AS MUCH AS I DO.
THEY ARE ADDICTED TO THE DAMN
THING.
WHAT YOU ARE GOING TO SEE A LOT
OF WHINING AND THROWING RATTLES
AROUND AND THEN THEY WILL ALL
COME DOWN AND PROBABLY FIND ELON
MUSK RESTORES TWITTER TO WHAT IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN WHICH IS A
FAIR, OPEN PLATFORM FOR PEOPLE
OF ALL PERSUASIONS AND ALL VIEWS
YOU SHOULDN'T BE LIVING IN AN
ECHO CHAMBER WHERE THE ONLY
PEOPLE YOU EVER SEE REPLY
TALKING ARE PEOPLE THAT AGREE
THEY LIKE THAT.
THE POLITICAL ON THE POLITICAL
LEFT LIKE THAT.
AND THEY DIDN'T LIKE THE FACT
THAT CONSERVATIVES HAD A POINT
OF VIEW THAT'S WHAT
CONSERVATIVES SAY.
SO GOING FORWARD, SUDDENLY,
PEOPLE ON THE POLITICAL RIGHT
ARE SEEING A WHOLE BUNCH OF
TWITTER FOLLOWERS EITHER RETURN
OR START TO FOLLOW THEM SO IT
LOOKS LIKE MAYBE ELON MUSK DID
OPEN THE FLOOD GATES.
>> WHAT WAS VERY INTERESTING
FOLLOWING ACCOUNT.
OVER THE LAST SIX OR SEVEN
MONTHS I HAVE NOTICED A GRADUAL
REDUCTION 8 UNTIL MILLION TO
7.90.
THIS IS WEIRD WIFE IS MY
FOLLOWER COUNT GONE DOWN.
CONSISTENTLY GONE UP AND LAST
TWO WEEKS IT'S GONE UP BACK TO
WHERE IT STARTED.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A
COINCIDENCE OR WHETHER THAT'S
THE ELON MUSK FACTOR ALREADY
GETTING INSIDE UNDER THE
UNDERBELLY OF TWITTER AND SAYING
ALL THIS KIND OF WEIRD STUFF HAS
TO STOP YOU CAN'T START SHADOW
BANNING PEOPLE.
ON THE RIGHT NOR IS ELON MUSK BY
THE WAY.
ELON MUSK IS NOT AN IDENTIFIED
CONSERVATIVE.
IS HE ACTUALLY SOMEBODY WHO
LOVES BERNIE SANDERS.
HE WANTS AN OPEN PLATFORM THOUGH
FOR EVERYBODY JOE ROGAN STRUCK
THE NAIL ON THE HEAD.
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT DON'T LIKE TO
HAVE THEIR OPINIONS CHALLENGED.
THEY HAVE THIS UTTER
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS THAT
EVERYTHING THEY SAY IS
SACROSANCT AND CANNOT BE
CHALLENGED.
UNTIL THAT CHANGES UNELECTABLE.
B STARTS TO KILL DEMOCRACY.
CHECK OUT HIS SHOW PIERS MORGAN
UNCENSORED DROPS EVERY AFTERNOON
WEEKDAYS 4:30 IN THE AFTERNOON
EASTERN TI